because uh i've done it dude i did so
many over
the course of a year where my cause my
manager gets me all my auditions i i'm
not with my i'm not with an agency
anymore
and
out of choice but like but he
he would be like this is really good
dude you should you i'm telling you this
is for succession you're not going to
audition for success and every time i'd
go okay and then i would do it and
nothing no notes
nothing whatsoever it was [ __ ]
pointless
it's not though you just never know him
you just proved it was you said
everything you ever got was because the
guy knew who you were i know
that's true but that is true but can i
say this though but also paint on to it
before you say this throw on top of it
too we don't really want to hire white
straight guys right now that's a huge
thing too all right your attitude right
now go you're not white and straight
because they all think i am you're
middle eastern i don't you're punjabi
like the other one i don't lean into it
i've said to my manager i go tell them
i'm [ __ ] arab if it helps yeah i
don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not arab enough
i'm not arab enough i pass for white no
here's what happened to you
this is what you purposely do dude
you're not in the sun enough
that's the key no i'm being real right
guys like this arab juice like this
right they don't they're not in the sun
enough right so go on the sun put some
tan i bet you might if you got dark
you'll get them all i can't get dark i'm
light-skinned dude yeah you look at like
most salah like you don't look anything
like most of the law
who's most allah oh muhammad from from
football
what no did you ever see this guy
yeah well forget i won't like that's an
egyptian that's an egyptian you could do
this you could do that dude there's
different that color you can do my hair
is too
it's not
what's the term for that
say it no i'm not saying it i'll say it
but froe froe is a good word right here
it's not that fro-y yeah is that racist
no no yeah it's froey yeah yeah um
but that would look like a mother like
look at mo amir that [ __ ] looks
like he sells falafel yeah
but
but
like you gotta look arab you know you
and i have to go to hawaii
a couple of a week on the beach i don't
tan up that much i'm trying to tell you
you don't do you have you tried yes
you think i don't go out
no but i'm saying really
what the [ __ ] i've had four weeks at a
at a beach house where i'm in the pool
every day for eight hours straight and
i'm telling you it only gets so tan it
just doesn't well you just pink no i'm
just kind of always this color it gets a
little darker okay
don't get any i'm gonna
don't get angry don't get angry
i'm gonna tell you something okay yeah
you sh
depending on what it is
you should always keep putting yourself
on tape because you never know
yeah it's like okay
okay i'm going to ask you a question
okay
i'm your manager yeah okay yeah and i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna give you three
projects and i wanna see which ones you
would take okay
okay hey derosa it's me what's his name
your guy zach it's me zach
good why do you have that accent now
zach oh i'm from the east coast now
hey but anyway
you good
yeah i'm good yeah i got some projects
bro you got to put yourself on tape okay
all right this next one is um you i do i
think you know i mean the the cast they
don't know you that well mm-hmm yeah i
mean in fact they don't know you at all
okay right but i'm gonna you know it's
uh it's got ryan reynolds yeah right
and uh
margot robbie
ryan reynolds margot robbie right right
they're getting divorced you're the
lawyer right oh yeah and i'm telling you
right now dude it's like you know the
casinos don't want they want a funny guy
they want an egyptian guy
who looks italian
a jesus guy who looks italian yeah right
if
it was ever this narrow i might consider
it
you would do that one if if yeah but
it's never that okay it could be if okay
sorry another way that happens here's
another one here's another one all right
the second one okay
it's uh hey what do you love right it's
called um
jawa
you know you the star wars oh i love you
they're doing yeah they're doing star
wars i'll do it you will i would go on
no matter what it is i'm obsessed with
star wars
all right so you it's a dream of mine to
be somewhere in the star wars universe
okay so here's the third one i'll do
star wars
i only need to pick one i picked it all
right
all right stop this accident all right
so anyways good to
talk to you all talk to you later all
right all right okay bye-bye latino
[Laughter]
george lopez
am i going to get canceled because i
said uh mo amir looks like he sells
falafel no no
no because i'm arab so it's okay
you worry about that no i was joking i'm
joking but you get worried do you worry
about uh
a little bit because i don't have [ __ ]
you money
i don't have [ __ ] you money who does i
can't go away there's five guys that has
[ __ ] money
if i had a millie in the bank i would be
like i don't care how many how much
million one
i don't i don't need much
if you had one million the bank [ __ ] you
i'll live i'll i i will live off of that
wow
you have a low overhead
that's good what am i what am i
what i care i'll buy i buy a house in
pennsylvania for 250 000
wow in cash and then i'll have 750 000
left and then i'll i'll have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] job in a comic book store and
pay my bills and have health insurance
what the [ __ ] else do i need to do
if i got canceled ah oh that's true if
you guys can't but you can always still
do the road
well no i'm saying if you got career for
real cancer now there are guys that that
really cancel
still do the professor still sells a lot
of tickets yeah and they sell still good
tickets yeah but i but i would but he's
he was that he had i don't know who
we're talking about he had dough i i'm
not talking about him
i don't think he was truly canceled
i don't even know who you're talking
about i think he was right there's a
couple of other ones that are truly
canceled still making money
i'm not talking about who you think i'm
talking about this has been the whole
podcast by the way yeah people all right
so listen i don't want to mention the
guy we're talking about but i'm just
saying no i think we're talking about
two different guys no i know i know
i know who you're talking about yeah
already but i'm telling you that's not
who i'm talking about no i know i just
said we're talking about two different
guys right right but i'm gonna say what
is canceled anymore i don't think they
truly cancel because
well again [ __ ] you money like like that
but even if but derosa if you get
cancelled and you can still sell out a
club you're not cancer sold yeah
i so there's no ones that's ever been
canceled but i i i can't sell out a full
weekend at a club i can sell okay
but i'm not i'm not worth the risk
the club isn't looking at me going dude
it's undeniable money we're [ __ ]
booking it they're not going to do that
like i will be like if i got canceled
right now i'd be doing like
at best
75 seats
like those kinds of rooms for the rest
of my life and i'm not gonna die doing
that you know so if you get a hundred
percent the door and you charge 40 bucks
i like doing shows like that i'm just
saying like i'm not going to burn myself
out to death like running around you
know you're right
i don't know don't get canceled then but
you don't worry like most of all it's
one of the hummus or whatever you just
said is not a bad thing you don't worry
about it at all
oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah i
can't tell when you're like actually mad
or serious or anything yeah that's why
i'm a deceiver you
know cool there i live in the shadow
that's a you all right that's a better
way to put it yeah i'm a deceiver sounds
negative
yeah i i um
number one um honestly 99